greetings my name is jake i'm here with
nick and we're about to play some co-op
in mario plus rabbids this might be one
of my favorite features in this game
uh it's a lot of fun requires a lot of
communication and here we are
at the character select screen who are
you gonna be nick
i wanna be only rabbits because i'm a
huge rabbit fan you want to do only
rabbits i'm going to be
mario rabbid and luigi rabbit actually
no i'll be peach rabbit
okay the cutest couple in all the rabid
land
all right let's do this i'm excited me
too
this game is actually pretty difficult
uh this shouldn't be too hard for us
just because i'm pretty far past in the
story like we've got good weapons
these characters have been upgraded and
so the objective for
this one is to simply reach reach the
other end
reach the other end all right i think
your team blue
and i'm team yellow correct
let's see oh seems like a lot of enemies
oh shoot there's one right there
[Music]
nice gone all right so now if i want
i still have one more character i can
move around but if i want i can just
switch to your turn right now
i think i'm gonna move luigi though okay
do you think you'll be able to take this
guy out oh
i slide into him because i can snipe
from here
all right luigi let's see if he can take
him it looks like he can take him down
oh you're gonna hit him
[Music]
teamwork makes the dream work i'm gonna
activate steely stair which
when someone moves uh you shouldn't
we're gonna activate it with mario as
well
and now it's you uh all right so i'll
come up here by you
and then i'll go ahead and jump down
he's got more range to him
or he he doesn't have a lot of range to
him and he's got
a lot of health so he's good to moving
close and he can destroy
barricades super easily he has a shotgun
right he's got a shotgun like thing
all right let's see what it does here
all right so damage some of the the area
and now uh rabbit peach will be our
healer
uh so yeah make sure to slide into this
dude first all right oh yeah freddie was
there so slide into him
and then i'll go here and watch the
right side okay
and just in case if he doesn't die i'll
shoot
nice nice
okay uh i'm assuming everyone's at a
range oh
maybe not oh yeah if you can hit him do
it
yeah we're actually pretty uh high level
for this
dang that was awesome i made short work
of him so what happened was
since i activated luigi's steely stare
when an enemy moves even if it's on my
turn and even if they don't move on
purpose
that'll trigger it and he'll shoot them
all right i'm going to go ahead
and finish our turn yep and let the
enemies go
a lot of big guys to start this round
tell me about these big guys what what
is
what is the oh there it is
so see ya if you shoot them they'll run
towards you doesn't matter where you are
on the map so if you're really far away
do it again if you're really far away uh
they'll still try to run for you unless
they're stuck in honey
which case they can't move so there's
honey that'll stop
some of the rabbits from moving there's
also stone i think
right there's stone which freezes them
for a turn
um there's ink which i forget what ink
does i think they can't use their
special
really
there are a lot of them there are okay
we just start pushing up
i don't use each other to jump if i can
dang i can't snipe him
all right i'm going to finish this guy
off right now oh he's out of bounds
hmm or he's not out of bounds he's out
of my range
you can jump here though yeah careful
though because you're a bunch of guys
up top on your left you're right maybe i
should let you take him out then
and i'll see if i can get up there to
these guys
they're pretty well covered though
i don't have in my sight there about
here
oh that's actually not a bad idea i
don't have it in my sight though
[Music]
i think i'm gonna risk it i think i'm
gonna land here okay
just because i want to deal with this
guy sooner rather than later
team mario's oh that may not even kill
him
we'll see critical hopefully
all right perfect so
i've got luigi
actually luigi can probably stay here
can he
can't shoot any of them yeah what i'll
do then maybe
jump off peach's head yeah that seems a
good move you got your back covered
there
wow still zero well i can at least do
some damage to
this cover oh so now when it's your turn
you should shoot that and he'll spring
off the edge
okay okay so i passed it over to you now
all right so
rabbit mario where should we bring him
maybe send him mario's direction
uh i'll go here yeah i think i'm safe
there
and i might be able to get a shot off on
some of those guys up top
no i think you're too far away yeah plus
i should get hit in the
crossfire all right uh okay so peach
we want peach to not be able to get down
there
hmm do i have the range to shoot that
uh uh i don't know hit uh lz or zl and
see
well maybe it'd go down actually i don't
know that pushes you can
go down there though oh that's right so
i go down
here can't get there though don't
actually make me further away
well hit lz see if you can shoot it from
here let's see
nope can't shoot it from there um
all right where do you want me to go
then i don't know
maybe just down there you're gonna have
to get off here eventually you might as
well start moving
yeah okay uh i will come down
man i guess i'll go here and just hope
no one's over here just hit me
peach very limited nope everybody's out
of range all right you have anything
else you want to do nope
we can pass to the enemies we go
oh blam
oh retreating
oh where'd that guy come from i have no
idea
good news is peach is a healer so
mario is taking some hits
man those two guys are right there oh oh
that's not good oh thank goodness i'll
probably have a shot on it here though
no fingers crossed this guy doesn't have
a shot
wow a lot of yeah lots of hidden stuff
okay so i got to get luigi the f out of
there actually but
can i i can shoot that though maybe
knock them off
whoa
[Music]
uh maybe go in that pipe kick him
that'll slide him head into the other
pipe
i don't know if i should because he's
right there and i don't have any attack
i can't attack
just get in cover so i'd see if you can
get peach to follow luigi over here
okay and then mario and mario rabbit
will follow the same path
yeah keep keep them together so that
each of us can jump off each other
uh luigi can jump two times right he can
do it
okay moving through here
all right gonna finish them off yeah
bam see ya
all right it's all you now all right uh
i guess i should come what does this do
uh that'll knock you away i think
uh i guess he's up there
so maybe i should go here yeah you might
even be able to have a shot on them from
there
let's do it but i think there's a guy
over there too actually
yeah you do have a shot on him yeah
there's a guy over there i should be
okay
i want to take my shot here or do i sing
a song and bring him to
see if you're
i can't see the other guy because the
camera's a little wonky but i'm gonna
bring him towards me
come to me good now he's in the red so
you'll kill him with this shot
all right but blam
got him dang if only we knew then you
could cover on this side
yeah from the other one but that's all
right oh shoot we got a rabbit over here
i'm alive
move away uh i need to get towards you
maybe getting cover on the other side of
that i'm moving too fast i got to slow
down a little bit i think
all right i'll get cover over there
uh zero percent
uh i guess i'll just shoot just to use
it
oh well that worked perfect okay
cool then let's move on to the enemies
oh boy they're gonna come after peach
rabbits make the coolest sound seriously
he'll do that too
oh hey
whoa
these two are being sneaky wow
he's taking some damage maybe he is near
him
[Music]
okay i'm gonna start with you this time
why don't you go first
switch to mario rabbid damn
all right uh or i guess you can
if you want to move peach with it go
through the pipe
then it'll go through the pipe uh with
him him okay
and now see if you can jump off mario's
head
[Music]
and then actually can you slide into him
first
i can't oh damn just that so jump off
mario's head
i get on the other side of that block
and just shotgun him oh actually wait a
second
oh who's over here get on this side of
the block because you could there's
friendly fire so you'd hit mario if
you've got over here and shotgun them
okay so just go right right here yeah
there we go mario gotcha
all right shotgun time ba-bam
stone nice and some coins so these two
guys are almost to the end
now where should i bring peach i don't
know
uh slide into him first
maybe get behind that rock and shoot at
him you might be able to finish him
if i go here or there
uh there's somebody over there he's over
there
i would i would go here probably right
here because i think you'll be able to
finish him
all right fingers crossed let's do this
whoa
and now we'll fire at him oh switch to
other ones see how much you
see what your other one will do i don't
know oh this one this one
that'll finish them so i'd use that
might as well let's do it
wow a lot of environments yeah seriously
okay cool now so now it's me
team y all right luigi what do you got
for me
[Music]
i feel like we're getting close to uh
we're very close to the end at least uh
luigi is
and you only need one of your team
members to make correct too
so now finish some point blank range
[Music]
nice
all right all right can't do a whole lot
but we're almost there with them too
okay
yeah we're good he's pretty safe back
there
peach might be fast forward to these
guys turns peach might be like
yeah i figured she was in there that was
it yeah oh really there's only one
[Music]
actually i should be helping you get to
the end i think uh yeah let me go and
maybe i can jump off you if i'm not far
[Music]
enough
this increases movement space by one for
everyone near him unfortunately
barely damn there's no one near him
[Music]
all right okay i'll switch to you so you
can get
rabid mario over there all right so
rabbit mario
oh actually i probably don't need it
yeah i guess not
we'll just go there excuse me i guess
i'll move mario too in that case then
and then uh where's that other guy
i wouldn't even worry about him i just
get peach to the objective just in case
she needs to be in that spot rather than
luigi yeah
uh okay so we'll go up here we'll go
through here
and then we'll hide here perfect covered
a lot of ground there
we go peach let's go let's go
okay uh i think that's it right or do
you need to move
i need to move him i need to move mario
uh okay
mario
oh nice there now you can use me to jump
to the end if you don't
get perfect perfect
uh okay i think that's it right fast
forward to the enemy team again
i actually thought more uh rabbids would
have hatched actually i think you need
to reach these so we'll switch to you
right now
yeah you're the one who needs to reach
the end on this side all right so i will
be the first one
in my team which means i'm good to go
you're good now i just need to get luigi
in on the other side and then we won
perfect so switch uh so switch to you
there we go that was it all right there
it is that's mario plus rabbits co-op
that was actually
pretty easy for us because i've unlocked
some new weapons i've on
i've leveled up my characters a little
bit so it wasn't too bad and we're
really good at this game
and we're good uh but anyway make sure
to check back to gamespot we will have
the review headed your way
and make sure to subscribe if you
enjoyed this really helps us out thank
you guys
see you guys